welcome good afternoon everybody you are
in the tutorial on Python debugging why
might this tutorial be interesting to
you now imagine you've been doing Python
data science for quite a while using
Jupiter notebooks and your program grows
bigger and bigger and bigger or you want
to take your data science pipeline from
a prototype stage into production then
eventually you might have to debug your
program in a different way instead of
just writing line by line and this is
where debugging actually becomes
important when your program grows when
you want to add more quality to it make
some extra checks and in this tutorial
we are going to exercise a few of the
most common debugging techniques in
Titan I would like to invite you to a
obstacle course to prepare this I wrote
a program a short piece of data analysis
and then I broke it I started building
bugs into my own program and we are
going to find and fix these bugs
together now I put a link for the entire
material here you also find it on github
but without some of the bigger data
files so if you want to try the full
thing then please take the bitly link
also at the end of this tutorial I'm
going to toss out a couple of books okay
let's go now what is the question that
we are going to deal with over the next
one and a half hours the goal I want to
tackle is this one the question are
monkeys and bananas genetically similar
iron biochemist by education I've spent
I think a decade analyzing biological
data
so these kind of things are around the
corner for me what does it mean how are
we going to do this imagine the
following we are looking at protein
sequences protein sequences are
basically character sings strings and we
want to count the characters and then
compare which characters are the most
frequent ones in monkeys which
characters are the most frequent ones in
bananas and for reference I also
included human data so that we have a
matter to compare that and there is in
the downloadable material there is a
Python script that does that and your
task is to go to this code it's in the
folder code buggy the program's name is
parse uniprot try to run it in Python
and then we are going to try to fix all
the bugs that we find I will accompany
that here in the front for those that
don't have a laptop underneath or didn't
fit it in the room anymore let's try
nope
and when you run the code what you
should see is something like this a
syntax error everybody of us has been
there probably on their first day trying
to program Titan syntax error the most
common error what can we do about such a
thing or have such a an exception any
suggestions how to fix a Python a syntax
error what we do to find the solution we
are looking here for techniques for
debugging how to get there
sorry is we couldn't use MV b and e b
what else first
first look at the source code which part
of the source code would you like to see
it starts with the very easy things
right so syntax error are the most
obvious errors that we can have or the
most the either ones that are the
easiest to find so it starts with
technique number one we read actually we
first read the error message then we
read the source code at the according
location
and what we see there is the reason for
the syntax error should be pretty
obvious to everybody okay so what's the
problem here missing : thank you there
we are now we can save the code and run
the program again another one now we are
done with the syntax errors the program
starts executing itself and we get a
runtime exception again we can try to
identify the source of the error by
reading the error message so I'll take
your suggestion that we had a couple of
minutes ago
and read the code at line 55 the sight
of the error message where is it line 55
I get the file not found error this is
the one of the other most frequent bugs
I think this is the most frequent
exception I've seen in my life as a
scientist and as a Python programmer as
well and it comes in all sorts of
flavors what's the problem here
did anyone find it already the file is
not present in the output folder exactly
so should I what how could I fix that so
we have to look a bit in two different
places it's called here at the very
bottom it's a little bit more difficult
because this line is not
self-sufficiently
pointing us to the error you get we are
actually trying to write a fire here
yeah so this is the output file we are
creating a file so we have to open it in
writing mode this can be already very
difficult to find if you are not
familiar with the code yourself if this
has written being written by someone
else or you have written this a long
time ago now I would like to point out
one interesting thing about these
exceptions and tighten if we read the
error message then the most obvious
things are the syntax errors these are
if something very obvious is wrong and
syntax errors they prevent your program
from starting altogether so no code gets
executed the second exception that we
had already author of a different kind
our program is the building and it
starts burning while we are using it so
we have to differentiate these two a bit
from each other why with the syntax
error
normally you find
the error at the site where that is
given in the error message with an
exception this is not necessarily so why
am i saying this in my opinion bugs in
Python are not always easy to find in
particular the error messages are not
always that helpful consider this
example I hope it's big enough for you
to read obvious error we forgot the
closing bracket okay
Python complains now compare what
happens if we forget the bracket on the
other side we get a different error
message and none of these two arab
messages is hey i was looking for a
bracket and did not find it it's a very
different experience of a very different
kind of message than those you get from
a c or java compiler so these pythons
error messages they have to pay be taken
with a grain of salt please don't treat
them as a goals than that sometimes they
mean something different then you see
anyway in this case we have found the
issue now what happens if we run our
code once again everything is fine at
least it seems we can check the output
folder and the one that i've created a
sample dot csv you should you shouldn't
have these other three on your machines
now at this point we might stop
debugging or can we
we should have a look we definitely
should have a look at the data file what
I see is this piece of explanation
what would we expect to see here first
we would expect to see all the counts of
the different characters from our input
file but what we see instead is a long
list of zeros the other thing that we
don't see is all the entries that
originated from our input file if we
look at the input file there should be a
couple of hundred different of these
string sequences so this repeats and the
program should generate one line of
output for each of those but there is
only one and it's empty so now we have a
third kind of error the program work
seems to work Python does not complain
but it does not do its job and at this
point debugging really starts and so we
have to dive into the program now and
see what is it actually doing we have no
error messages that could help us
anymore now at this point I would like
to introduce one of the most popular
debugging techniques in Python you all
know it what could we do to diagnose
what our program is doing print
print is quite a nasty debugging
technique it works most of the time it's
not elegant it's a little bit like like
shooting holes into into a building to
see whether there is a fire inside this
is my my own image for print for
debugging but somehow it works 90% of
the cases now where could we actually
start printing something here great
let's add a print to line 61 what should
I print yeah
I'll print everything that comes out of
the for loop for start
okay so it looks as if our input file is
at least read more or less correctly we
arrived at the point where the print
statement is reached and where it gets
data more than one entry obviously yeah
there is more than one entry appearing
on the screen pointing us to the fact
that the data is actually there this is
an important piece of information that
we did not have before okay so we know
up to this point things seem to be okay
now if we get stuck at this point we
could add a lot of print and mass print
statements and print everything at every
possible point in our program and when
you do this you will start realizing why
I think print is not the ideal solution
for every debugging problem because if
we print everything everywhere we first
we will mess up our entire program
second we will have to remove the print
statements afterwards and third we are
generating so much output that it might
be difficult to see what we are actually
looking for time for debugging technique
number three I was used to refer to this
as the scientific method this is not an
invention on my own I heard it from
andreas Zeller whom I consider an
authority on debugging software and what
it comes down as something that you as
data scientists should be familiar with
and that is we make hypotheses about our
program and make and predict prediction
not using machine learning this time
using our own mind what might be the
reason for
thing we see that anyone has a
hypothesis about what could be a reason
that the program is not doing what it
should the header parsing seems to feel
failed
okay something-something in the header
parsing seems to be wrong and now with
this hypothesis we could start on to
make predictions and then prove them
does anyone have a different hypothesis
because they are still more than one
bucket to find in this one yeah so the
hypothesis how your hypothesis is that
the AAA that encoded as a string might
be wrong let's let's stick with this one
because it's closer to the issue at hand
so the hypothesis is that a a is a
string whereas it should be a variable
in line 67 and the prediction is for
that that because of that we don't see
anything in the output or we could
predict that because of that we are not
counting the amino acids properly well
this is something that we can check now
let's add another print statement
and see whether they are in fact empty
and it seems that your hypothesis is
absolutely valid we are not counting
anything at the moment but the
occurrence of a lowercase AAA which we
don't have because all our input data
consists of capital letters and with
that we have a fix at hand
we remove the quotes we might keep the
print statements inside for the time
being much better isn't it now is anyone
here in the room who had to make a
hypothesis while debugging before and in
what situations does this technique
prove useful when you know the expected
results when you have some reproducible
way of checking whether your program
executes correctly which may involve
manually checking their output file like
we do it here you could do a manual and
automated test there which is not our
topic today okay but it's kind of around
the corner' also what I sometimes do is
I write down the issues that are that
I'm seeing some people write this as
github tickets yeah I sometimes use a
notepad for seeing for problems that I
cannot solve within the first few
minutes because when you keep staring at
a bug and keep staring at it for for 15
minutes 20 minutes all the time that is
left until midnight or whenever your
your stuff needs to be deployed then it
gets hard to remember after some time
what actually was the issue that you
start
so this is where this is an important
point about this technique number three
is to keep some kind of notes that
describe what the problem actually is
okay looks much better I could remove
the prints now simply because I don't
like to see them in my code now of
course I don't see anything anymore
and I can look at the output hooray the
numbers are there still something is
missing we only get one entry in the
output file now imagine you've been
debugging for a couple of hours and you
get to the point where you get stuck on
this kind of bug and at that when you
get there I would like to recommend you
one more debugging technique that has
not much to do with computers it has to
do with humans and that is talk to
someone talk to someone some I've heard
or it maybe it's a programmers miss
maybe some people are really doing this
that's explaining the problem to someone
some programmers are said to use a
rubber duck for that and they say if you
can explain the problem to a rubber duck
then maybe this already helps you by
verbalizing this that you find come to a
solution earlier so we are stuck with
the problem that we see only one output
entry so try try the rubber duck
technique I prefer to talk to people
actually instead of ducks please turn to
each other for one two minutes
reason or try to explain each other what
the problem is what
might be the possible reason if you have
found a solution already then think
about what other problems might there be
around the corner talk to each other he
knows of course
okay
okay listen up please I know this is a
very fruitful exercise to talk to ducks
are not very responsive people are
usually it's fun to do and you have may
have sudden insight did you have any
insights about the problem at hand here
yeah you did what what's the problem
here
we can we can indent a row here this is
a very common thing that is either that
Python is prone to produce especially if
you migrate from other programming
languages or you are still still in the
beginner stage where you need to realize
that indentation has a semantic meaning
and in this case yeah we are stepping
out of the loop too early so we need to
step inside and indent this by I think
it is by one level of indentation please
correct me if I'm wrong here
this should do it now let's see whether
that helped whoa I see lots of output
suddenly now I step back into the
program did you have any other insights
while talking any other things that
might deserve fixing or improving maybe
I was interrupting you too early
probably well whether you asked me
personally I thought that's actually a
great question
no actually I'm very unhappy about about
the format of the the output personally
I think it is very obscure yeah it's
hard to see what the data actually is
about yeah why is it sort of does anyone
else have this problem that the that the
output is not very easy to read this
looks like machine readable that it
definitely does not look human readable
the result the main reason why it's hard
to read so it's every every entry is one
line is not so bad basically but the
font size is too big yeah it comes you
know that's the trade-off when you when
you do trainings with with 60 people
then you have to take a bigger font size
but I take your point oh wow I even
wasn't aware of that really really good
you just found you just found an issue
with this code that I hadn't found
before
so there are commas in the description
if we again read this into pandas then
this will this will fiow will fly into
our face yeah actually all this string
like stuff there at the beginning the
annotation that tells us what kind of
protein is this basically if we just
want to count things then for the time
being we don't need this we have a
unique identifier for that the accession
number I think it's here is these
numbers that look a little bit like old
school secret keys here in the middle
these are the ones that that we would
like to have
the output and we can get rid of all the
rest and this is a great kind of thing
that you find find out while talking
about your code with another person so
when we create create the output here
then I would like to get rid of the
sequence name that is there in order to
make the output shorter easier to read
have it everything in one line that
maybe even here fits on the screen
widths and now now the issue comes back
that that you mentioned earlier about
that we have some some other issue
regarding the parsing but let's see
first what we see what we see here we
still have lots of text in the output
even though so that is because the name
and the accession are swapped you during
the parsing this part here some of you
may have found it already so we can
simply exchange the order fine fine
this is an unused piece of code it's
dead code happens when you write when
you write program it is like on a
construction site when you heavily work
there then after some time you have
parts lying around and this is something
what we are now doing is we are using
something that is not directly a a pro a
debugging technique but it definitely
helps with debugging we are cleaning up
so we are both cleaning up our code we
are cleaning up our output file I'll get
rid of the fragment it's not being it's
not good for anything okay saves us one
line and it saves us nerves later maybe
well chosen font size maybe so now we
are getting there this is the kind of
thing we would like to have as input for
a panda script before we continue to
read the code into a table and start
evaluating this there's another thing I
would like to try that debugging
technique number six I would like to try
a simple assertion here Python software
engineers they argue from time to time
whether putting asserts in a program is
a good idea or not and I don't have a
final opinion on that but on for this
kind of debugging making sure our data
is consistent actually pays off I would
like you to try the following I want to
have an assertion here that checks
whether the length we are putting into
the file is actually the same as the sum
of the characters we are counting should
be obvious if we have if we put a
sequence of a given length inside then
we would expect to count as many things
as there are characters in the string
could be but when we run this we get an
assertion error so this a surgeon does
not hold for at least one of the at
least for one of the strings in our data
set now how can we so this is good for
for making sure the data is consistent
but it doesn't so it helps us to
discover whether there is a problem so
how do we find the issue at this point
we are ready to use some of the heavier
machinery
I'm not going to start looking for the
source of this a certain problem with
print we could do that I think the
program still has a small enough size
for this but instead we are going to use
the interactive debugger or not do we
have number seven
it's pvb some people claim IP DB is even
better but the differences are small if
you don't have IP DB installed you can
use P DB and everything is fine now when
we start using it going into an
interactive debugging session the thing
that I usually do is I call the debugger
from my code I could call the debugger
from the command line as well but I'll
do it like this now I know this is not
like you write Python every day this is
one of the few situations where I find
it justified to put more than one Python
command into one line okay if you see if
you think this is still too ugly make it
- it doesn't matter and when we start
the code then we get in to a debugging
prompt that starts with PDB who of you
has been in the interactive debugger
before quite a few okay great so we have
a couple of commands that are available
here which do we have what could we do
now sorry
we can we can step through the code but
I actually I don't know where and the
code we are L so if I type L I see a
portion of the program plus a small
arrow that tells me where we are at this
very moment which the arrow points to
the line that would be executed next and
now we can step through the program we
can execute our code in slow motion this
is great it's like doing the same thing
you are used from Jupiter notebook but
on a on a smaller scale stepping through
all the cycles of a for loop if you want
to it's a great tool for debugging it's
really tiny machinery that we are using
here what um okay how do we step which
is the command so that I put it in the
slides you have it on github but maybe
anyone from the audience remembers how
could we execute the next line for is
now continue continue just starts
running our program normally and for
next so here this execute the next line
brings us to the next and we can execute
our program one by one after some time
it pays off to press L again and we can
then see where we are and has a cousin
that is s which I will not use right now
because what what happened then is we
get to execute the function that we are
calling at the moment in this case the
powers header function and continue our
interactive session there until we are
done oh now I did it
great so I'll just step through the
through the lines one by one I hope
there is no loop here this is how
interactive debugging sometimes looks
like until we reach the return statement
and at which point we get back to our
original program from where we left so
this this is the s command it steps into
a function and start interactively
debugging this now how is PD be useful
for diagnostics we have here a lot of
the normal things available that we can
do on the Titan console that means we
can inspect variables we can use
introspection functions we can change we
can we can modify values of variables so
for instance if I'm at this point here
then I could check what the length
actually is it's 156 great I could check
what the type of my length is I could
use functions like dear where I can see
what that my name space consists of
which variables do I have I could use a
function like locals that gives me all
the local variables and their content
now this was maybe a bit fast what I
typed was
was this function which I don't find too
useful in other contexts but in an
interactive debugging session it's great
now we found out about the length and
now we reach the for loop I what I would
like to see to trace the source of our
bug is to actually compare manually the
lengths that we calculate with the count
list that we calculate now the problem
when we reach the for loop is that our
program upon executing this these lines
iteratively by the next commanded that
we have to go through the cycle many
times and this is very annoying this is
very nunnery I don't want to do this
manually so what I do here is I will set
a breakpoint a breakpoint means I want
to have a point in the program where it
runs to and then as soon as it reaches
the breakpoint it stops I place a great
point with the B command in line 68 so
the debugger tells me you've created a
breakpoint at line 68 and now I can use
this C command for continuum which tells
me continue the program until it either
ends or you reach a bit a breakpoint so
this will complete the entire for loop
for us so what we what have we seen we
have seen quite a couple of debugging
commands here l and s B and C there's
another one you may find useful that's Q
for quit if we see we cannot save our
session anymore we want to get out of it
and start again
then Q is the right one to suppress
now let's see what we found we have the
lengths by now and we have a a count oh
it's a a counts and we could now check
the search manually by checking some AAA
counts and see well it's a different
number we have a length of 156 and but
we calculate 153 in total has anyone
figured out how how how we could find
out what the problem is or what else
could we look at here at this point the
input data might be wrong so let's look
at the input data but we derived the
length from the input data so we
calculate the length of a string and the
string is this one we have to strip it
so we see okay there are new lines that
messed up the data where we are doing
the counting so at this point I have
enough information I know what the
problem is I'll get out of the debugging
session and back to the program and see
okay where what did I forget to strip
something it's here
yes
sorry could you could you repeat the
question please yes you can do that so
if we are inside the the debugger
let's get inside again and we have some
local variables here for instance the
length and I want to see whether the
program would execute correctly with a
different length now so I could say
length should be now 156 you can do that
okay now now I would be changing it from
the correct to the wrong value because
153 works right already yeah so but yes
you could you could do the older editing
you have access to all the Python
functions here we could replace the new
lines here inside the debugger now let's
let's continue and again we have an
assertion error so what does this
assertion error tell us it's still the
same issue but we fixed we thought we
fixed it already
now we fixed it for one of the of the
entries there might be other bugs for
other input data the problem is how to
find those wrong entries okay so let's
say you're you're used to working with
big data sets let's say you have 10,000
entries in your input file and entry
9700 is for somehow somehow false and
causes a problem with would cause this
kind of a search in error what you
definitely cannot do is to go into the
interactive debugging session and say
hey I manually will skip the
first 9000 699 entries and then finally
after a couple of hours I will be at the
one that is eventually wrong we could
use print statements which is not ideal
either here I'm going to use another
feature of the interactive debugger
which are conditional breakpoints
conditional breakpoints consists of you
set them by typing a deal then a line
number you could also use the name of a
function and a Python conditional
expression we can use the same
conditional expression here as we did in
our assertion now let's let's check I go
into the interactive debugger I say I
want to have a conditional breakpoint
right before the assertion I need to
know the note the line number for that
so I check my code search for the
assertion and I would like to have a
breakpoint here at line 69 because I
know until then everything should be
fine because it fails only in line 71 so
I say breakpoint at line 69 with the
condition length is not equal to the sum
of my list of counts okay this means
this is very flexible so this breakpoint
will only stop if the condition applies
so it means it will skip all the correct
entries and stop at the one that we know
will fail the assertion so and now I can
press Continue and wait and see where
the interactive debugger actually is
going to stop now we are here no
surprise at the breakpoint it's marked
by the small B on the left side and we
can check what data did we actually get
and I look at my input string does
anyone spot a potential issue now the
quotes are there because it's a string
there's no space inside now this is this
is a nasty one there's no X are you a
biologist you either have to look what
actually are we parsing there what
characters are we counting or you have
to have the expert knowledge that tells
you immediately oh there's an X this
means missing data this is the
corresponding thing to an NA N and we
see okay
well the X is not among the characters
that we are counting in the first place
sometimes you find those things is if
you are a biologist you know you know
you know will notice this immediately if
you are a data scientist with an expert
knowledge in some other domain this
might go unnoticed unnoticed for quite a
while and this is why I'm happy about
that I'm having this assert in the code
to reinforce my code against this X
slipping through so we have of course to
decide to have some strategy against
against this kind of missing data
because there's more than one X in the
data set in this case I know enough
already and I'm going to fix the thing
on the parser side simply by replacing
all XS
by nothing you can think of a smarter
way to resolve the issue and maybe
there's even better solutions so if
there's if there was a what a wire okay
if there's this amino acid alphabet
consists of twenty characters right an O
for instance always not included B is
not included then yeah then we would
have to we would have to make a maybe
make a regular expression out of this I
check whether this works because I think
there are no O's and B's in my code oh I
still have the call to the to the
interactive debugger here now I just
continue and I mistyped thee I mistyped
the syntax in my hotfix
here and now it runs all the assertions
have passed this is the point where I'm
really happy about the result and here I
have some real liability about the
result actually being correct did anyone
find any other issue with the code
there's one more bucket inside that is
very difficult to find with our sample
data file
the homo ii spelling this this Homo
Sapien spelling actually is being messed
with there is a bug here in line 49 very
good it's the name is converted to
lowercase and then something in mixed
upper and lowercase is being searched
there but we just removed working with
the name so this is actually dead code
week we might as well throw it away you
got another one I think oh it's still in
the header so we should make this nice
otherwise pandas will have column labels
messed up so we need to remove the name
here
excellent what else could we do any any
other issues yeah I think I removed this
already sometime ago oh no I didn't okay
we might skip this entire function
powers header except the part that gives
us the accession number this would
actually simplify the code make it
easier to maintain yeah this goes a bit
into the into the topic of refactoring
which I don't want to dive into today
yeah but yes this is something that we
we might do one issue that it's hard to
find and for this we need again to look
at our input data something we might
have started with but you came you came
up with very smart debugging suggestions
quite early our sample input file
consists of I think one thousand lines
this is not a very convenient size for
debugging
actually I would prefer to have a
smaller input file in fact I would like
to have a input file that is as small as
possible so I get to my input data again
and I would like to extract just two
entries here and I create create a new
file and then I make the input even
shorter I make one one sequence a name
it Python and I skipped most of the crap
from the header and the other sequence
is just data and I call this mini dot
fast a so why why am I doing this
what do you think
exactly I'm I what I'm now doing is
manual unit testing
I could easily automate a test like this
I could calculate the correct result
and with our with my fingers my kids
could calculate the the correct results
from this they can do this they could
not do this uh with with the full sample
fast effect because the numbers get too
big and the the outcome should be kind
of obvious so which means I need to run
the sample export the sample for my mini
input file I run the code again and at
this point I could I probably could
remove the debugging statement what went
wrong now
yes I did this by putting the
conditional breakpoint right before the
assert statement there's more
alternatives to that yeah I could for
instance on run we run the code from
from I tighten and then I get I could do
a post-mortem analysis that means the
program crashes with the assertion error
and I can examine the last frame that
Python was executing I could look at all
the variables they don't just disappear
they are still there but it's postmortem
it's called post-mortem the name is not
a coincidence it's like examining a dead
body up because if you cannot execute
anything anymore
we cannot rewind the program execution
by one frame so the problem here of
course that there is no Oh in protein so
I have to take a cue in tight in here so
now let's see how this works and I want
to see the output for my minimal input
fire and what I see is this so I see an
output that I now can easily check
manually so the first entry was Python
Python has six characters and now I
could match the columns the last one is
the why seems to work where which one is
the next to the front one two three four
five six seven that's the age so and I
can check other six ones in the in the
entry great works but now at this point
I should have discovered that there is a
bug in the code that we did not figure
out before what's the problem here
the second we had a second entry it's
missing where it has it gone
has anyone found the place in the code
already we could now go through the
entire cycle of diagnosing this program
step by step again but this is something
that it's very easily forgotten when you
write file parsers if you have some
custom file format and you need to parse
it then this tends to happen over and
over again if I look at my generator
function that generates pairs of header
and sequence with the yield statement
there in the middle this is basically a
question for those who are more familiar
with generator functions and we process
we process our our entries one by one
somewhere in the middle yields them but
we will also need a second yield here in
the middle at the end of the function
and this is the one that was lacking
that produces of the very last line the
very last entry for from the from the
data we read
so okay so what happens we start reading
the file interpret some data the thing
is that we that yield always are gives
back one pair of header and the string
to do that it needs to know that the
entry is complete that we have collected
all the lines containing text data and
in order to do that and how the function
recognizes that is by seeing that the
next entry is starting that's the if at
the at the top if line that starts with
greater than this is the signal
okay the next entry has started we need
to first yield the the old one before we
can start parsing the next and this way
you you miss out the last one because
there is no starting signal for the for
the next entry and this is why this dude
is necessary here this string based
format it's a classic that is used by by
computational biologists around the
world and parsing this kind of file
format is a very good exercise that I
don't know probably hundreds of
thousands of people have done already
and it's good to try this because you
stumble upon these kinds of issues there
over and over okay now with this we have
covered quite a few different debugging
techniques before I would like to switch
to introduce the last one that I have
prepared here I would like to ask you
other other debugging techniques that
are worth mentioning at this point what
else could we do to make our program
better make it more correct
so it's like uh it's like simply simply
going through and drive driving through
the mud and seeing whether you get to
the end of the road and then eventually
take care of the dirty things later okay
yeah so how should I put this on the
board okay try except I would like to
Kenya can i summarize your your strategy
that works with try/except okay try
except count how many entries you lost I
find it's a very very viable strategy
because pandas is actually quite good at
dealing with missing or dirty data you
can actually still do your plots even as
half of your data sets set consists of
Na ends great thank you
what else can we do tests so-so tests
hey payoffs are very greatly when you
know you will have to maintain your code
over a longer time if you're just doing
prototyping and you know your code is
going to change rapidly
there is no not really a point in in
writing tests because then you will have
to to change twice as much code when
your code is changing but if you know I
want this to be stable I want this to be
reliable I want to have parts that I can
combine great this is something that I
would consider for this read fast a
function to test to write unit tests for
this or I could or I could write pip
installed by up
Ayten and then use the already existing
parser for that would save me a couple
of lines but then all of you would have
to install it any other strategies you
got one so a linter is anyone using a
linter here that's pilant or pi flakes
yeah what are the brief summary what
does it give you for for everybody who
doesn't
so the linter points out syntax errors
things that might be potential errors of
style issues so unused variables are a
potential source of errors variables
that you initialize twice are a
potential source of errors so there's
quite a lot of things that the linter is
quite useful to prevent bugs from
happening the good news for you is if
you are using anaconda or if you are
using PyCharm
then you probably have one of those
linters already built-in so all the pet
eight issues they get highlighted by
some some underlining if you are using
sublime there's a plugin for for linters
and i heavily recommend you to use them
if i if i start if i start answering
this question then then we'll be
brawling here in the room i think in the
which coin it I think it really depends
on what what tool you are used to so I I
prefer to do debugging from the command
line because this is this is what I grew
up with okay mmm some people they run
their code from from within sublime
others they start the code from anaconda
where you have where you can do the same
things as well PDB but you have buttons
for that also great if you like that
putting in breakpoints in your code is
very convenient in pycharm and anaconda
and but I'm I'm a little bit reluctant
to give a general recommendation on
editors when I learned programming on
one arm once when my mentor was trying
to convince me to use use Emacs he tried
for four years and he was not successful
otherwise this would be a lisp tutorial
so the linter Pyland
PI flags you've got another one
yes let's that's a good one I've seen
that happening in in anaconda too quite
a lot that is if you run your program it
still uses the variables that are left
over from the previous one and in
Jupiter of course this will happen as
well really dr. Tucker dozens of cash
stuff
can I can I add container here yes one
thing we are not covering here is are
any all kinds of bisection strategies
that is imagine you are you have some
some huge data set and you know the that
some part somewhere in the data set
there is a data arrow some kind of
inconsistency but it's not as easy as in
our case to find out where it is so what
you can do then is to partition your
data sets test both parts independently
see is it in the left slice is it in the
right slide then partition the one again
until after a log n number of iterations
you find one line or a few lines that
are the source of the problem you got
one more
I come to that I still need to write up
the one that I mentioned previously that
was the bisection strategy there's a
very sophisticated procedure that is
called Delta debugging it's in the same
github repository as this tutorial which
mainly allows you to identify if there's
two lines in your input that create a
problem only if they are together then
Delta debugging is an automated
procedure that allows you to locate this
it's a cool one but it's very it's very
sophisticated and I only found very few
use cases for that so this is why I'm
did not put this here so regarding your
suggestion aren't about outputting line
numbers so this goes a little bit into
the direction that I would like to
mention or allow us to try out at the
end of this tutorial and that is logging
I have an example for logging why do I
mention logging here in this tutorial
it's because when your program grows
bigger let's say a dozen a couple of
hundred lines a cup about 1,000 lines of
code you won't get very far with print
anymore then print becomes something
between annoying and completely useless
because it does more harm than good what
you will need then is logging and this
is my my final debugging technique here
yes
so what I mean by logging is that we
write our program in such a way that it
produces some meta information that
accompanied the output so in addition to
our primary output file we generate some
second file that allows us to to see
what the program was doing so where the
program tells in a little bit more words
what actually did happen so like I read
entry number one i processed entry
number one then I read entry number two
then I read entry number two then I
wrote an output line for entry number
two in entry number three I found
something dirty so I skipped it and so
on and the thing is that I would like to
show you here is that logging in Titan
is super easy to use yeah you can build
a lot of lot of things on top of logging
you can use this dedicated logging
server you can build a search engine on
your logs if they get huge I'm not I'm
not even poking into that okay you can
use other log formats than having text
files fine
try it but the most basic thing for the
average data science pipeline is that
you collect useful information in a
second file that you might want to look
at later and how does this work there is
a built-in module in Python that is
called logging and we need to initialize
this which basically means we say hey
all our logs should go into this file
debug dot log and we set the logging
level to warning this will need a bit of
info of explanation in a second and then
when we have set up this we can from
anywhere in our program including
different modules we can use a couple of
functions like logging
got info logging dot debug that result
in a string being written to the log I
can try this the program executes and I
end up with a with two messages in my
log that consists of three pieces of
information on the right there is the
string that I actually sent to the
logging module here for instance
factorial calculation ended this is what
I created here at the very bottom of the
of the script then before that there is
root which is the the identity of the
logger root is the default it has
nothing I'm not running my script as a
super user yeah and the if you are you
can define multiple loggers and give
them different names I didn't care about
this and the first one is the serious
city of the logging level and this is
what I specify here at the beginning I
say I want only everything that is a
warning or more serious and they of
these logging levels there are five in
total the most serious ones are critical
messages when there come arrest warrant
debug and info if you set your logging
level to info you will see everything in
your log yeah we can try that if we
change this in our program if you write
info here then all the log messages like
info and debug will also be written to
the log so our log file becomes longer
by changing a single variable
this is what we get yeah so by toggling
a little switch somewhere we can
determine how much useful information
our program is going to produce and if
you are building a pipeline this is one
of the nice things that you can build in
questions regarding logging that one
mm-hmm so why is there no o'er no time
stamp given because you have to
configure the the logger to give at
times then I have some more example
examples of using the logging module
here and the second one has a template
string with the date format where you
can you actually put in a timestamp but
I commented this out yeah so you have to
switch this timestamp on explicitly it's
there other questions regarding logging
okay then I come to summarize this
tutorial in a moment and give you some
extra hints but first of all I need to
do something with you I brought I
brought a pile of pile of small cards I
hope you have pens with you some of
these they are a little bit wet because
we had a bit of rain two days ago
since there are quite a few of you here
and I would like to ask you to make
smaller too small to cut them into into
two smaller pieces or rip them into two
smaller pieces
write your name into these because I
brought
a few copies of my of my book which I
would like to to hand out to three lucky
winners here at the end of the tutorial
so we need to what we need to pass this
around write your name on a piece of
card and I uh
we are going to draw three winners at
the end could you could you pass this
around if we run out of cards then
please
please take some other piece of paper it
will be I'll close my eyes okay
so okay what do we need to remember
about debugging so first of all
debugging is not a random activity it's
not something that comes by itself if
you look at your code hard enough number
one second debugging in Python is not is
not necessarily easy there there are
many places where on where bugs can hide
and this has to do with Python being a
dynamically typed language so when you
write C or Java code then your are your
compiler will catch quite a lot of bugs
for you in particular type errors
oh oh I think I love a lot number eight
eight as well um does anyone remember
what we had here sorry minimizing input
thank you thank you for the question
both both actually but um in a sense
this is why you all when you test your
program you need to do both you need to
test your some minimal input to see
whether the general mechanics are in
place whether something important got
lost and you also need to test it with a
bigger input file to see whether it
actually performs on on a bigger output
regarding this on this monkey data there
is it there is a script in the folder in
the git repository that actually
consists that contains a few more small
bugs you can actually take this and try
out whether you find out whether monkeys
and bananas are genetically similar
similar to each other than humans
there is a dedicated Python library for
for that I think it's called hypothesis
I haven't used it myself
but it's a library that generate that
takes your data or take some certain
rules and generates random data and it's
been described as a very effective
technique to find bugs that otherwise
would have been lost thank you okay so
this is more or less an an overview of
how you can debug code in Python so I've
written a couple of chapters on on
debugging and I'm some of these end up
in tutorials like this or on my on my
blog I'll be around for questions after
the tutorial and when I've finished the
tutorial in a moment and then draw the
lucky winners before before everybody
gets out could we collect the are the
codes of the names niblets in some kind
of device does anyone have it have a
small bag I did oh wait I got a jungle
girls bag let's take this one could you
pass could you pass through and collect
all the all the ballots so that we can
draw some
I was trying to think about in which
order to proceed but it really depends a
bit on arm on how what is your young
programming workflow in some project I
would advocate before doing anything of
this start to some test-driven
development
write a test first before you even think
about debugging in others you can take
the bugs and deal with them as they as
they appear sometimes I never get to the
stage where I have to start the
interactive debugger and other code
examples I don't seem to get out of this
year at all yeah so consider this a kind
of toolbox that helps you to make your
Python code more reliable and get to the
get to a working state easier there's a
last thing that I would like to mention
that is also an important debugging
technique and that is number 10 here
debugging is the tiresome activity some
people claim it's twice as hard as
programming which is why a develop
debugging technique is taking a break
which is what we hopefully will do right
after the ballots are complete oh we are
done ok
doesn't matter I'll I'll take them from
the ground I pick one from the from the
bag one from the ground
let's get them inside
let's see whether anyone wrote Seedorf
and awesome
okay we got one lucky VIN winner here
Paley lets you okay congratulations
[Applause]
second edition of Python best practice
code to Hawaii whoa
and number three goes to Alex clink
that's it for for today I am it was a
pleasure for me to be here at PI data
and enjoy the rest of the evening see
you at the lightning talks
thank you
[Applause]